- [Narrator] Tell me if
this voice sounds familiar.
- [Man] Sweet lion of Zion!
- [Narrator] What about this one?
- [Man] In brightest
day, in blackest night.
- [Narrator] Okay, you
definitely know this one.
- 50 years have passed, and I do not age.
- [Narrator] We could
easily keep going through
his 300 other characters, but
let's just cut to the chase
and meet the man behind the voice.
(energetic music)
This is Phil LaMarr,
and he's a voice actor.
- I'd say the ones that I'm
probably best known for,
Hermes Conrad, certified bureaucrat,
from the show “Futurama.”
- Great cow of Moscow!
Virgil, Virgil Hawkins, aka Static Shock,
from “Static Shock.”
John Stewart, Green Lantern,
from “Justice League.”
- No evil shall escape my sight.
- Ollie Williams, the
weatherman, from “Family Guy.”
- Ollie Williams has the story, Ollie?
- I'm at the wrong airport.
- Oops, well thanks, Ollie.
- Wilt, from “Foster's Home
for Imaginary Friends.”
One of my favorites is Dracula
from “Grim Adventures of Billy and Mandy.”
And of course, the samurai
known as Jack, from the cities
of the same name.
- He who wears a mask cannot
see what lies within himself.
- When I was working on “Pulp Fiction,”
(record scratches)
- [Narrator] Wait, you were in
“Pulp Fiction”?
- Of course, yep.
Here, let me jog your memory.
(fun surf music)
- Marvin, Marvin, Marvin!
I'd knock that (expletive) off if I was you.
- [Narrator] Ohhh, you're Marvin.
- [Phil] And I was one of
the original cast members
on Fox's “MADtv.”
- [Narrator] No way, I love MADtv.
- Then you must have been a
14-year-old boy in the ‘90s.
- [Narrator] Very funny,
Phil, anyway, you were saying?
- With Samurai Jack I felt
there should be some tie
to his roots.
So it was a very light Japanese
accent on English, we began
to refer to as a young
Asian Clint Eastwood voice.
- [Narrator] And Hermes from “Futurama,”
where did that voice come from?
- When I first started out
doing the Jamaican accent
for Hermes, it was pretty
much a heavy puhtwah.
And it muddied up the comedy,
so eventually your Hermes
accent got pulled back,
which is a lot easier to understand.
- [Narrator] What about John
Stewart from “Justice League”?
- To me, if you got a chest this big,
you gotta have a deep voice.
My name is John Stewart,
Green Lantern of Sector 2814.
- [Narrator] And how about Static Shock?
- That voice was basically
just myself at 14.
It was just that idea
of, you know, a young kid,
you know, who's a responsible guy but,
you know, he just happens
to have electrical powers.
And to me, that is the
character I relate to the most.
You know, Static is just, you know, me.
(lively jazz music)
The differences between
stage, film, voice acting
are really technical.
If that plane leaves and you're not on it,
you're gonna regret it.
One of the benefits we have in animation
is, I can play this guy, and
I can also play this guy.
- You'll see what I'm talking about.
- Just right there in
the same day, same room,
same microphone, you know ‘cause
that's why we got into it,
to play characters.
You will bow before the Kah.
(lively jazz music)
(electronic tones playing)